yeah I welcome to this video what do we
do here the offbeat week what is off
beat him what can you blame them to me
even the Duchess of bitter maybe some d6
stuff what do we get now it's a bit
tricky i mean offbeat does not mean that
i want to play plain nonsense yeah i
don't play the Anglin gambit or so maybe
what about this that check check defense
that's a bit a bit dubious because of f1
but i'm not sure let's see how how bad
it is yeah the usual problem is what has
a good center so let's see 93 is it's
the most testing move now i think
yeah Knight f3 Bishop g4 Bishop e3 I
believe this is at least how I played it
once with white when I got it you should
be three not that this is the only rule
button just make some sense okay so
maybe just trying to develop yeah it's
not so clear what blacks compensation is
for being the center down yeah what is
my compensation this is really an
opening that people play it some kind of
surprising considering how weird it
looks mp5 okay I gained some space there
on the green side at least what about c5
can I do that forcing some sort of
concession there on the in the center if
he plays d5 I get some control over 5
know it just takes that's also just
better
and wow what a rubbish position I can
get this lucky Fe night ft 7 might still
be okay it may be on a good day I
managed to place your form must be a
very good day now well night ft 74 is
not that that outlandish to hope for
yeah a night at night at five I
absolutely cannot allow so let's do this
I met on the clock that's it's something
maybe he can take on me 59 and I'd ft 7
e 6 or something like that takes on an
e5 okay let's cool down if it takes you
five I can take on e5 week just
recapture and I'm really threatening see
for now that might be well threat threat
is a strong word but I can't play it
let's say
yeah my king is really really shaky him
the only thing is that he's currently
his pieces are not so active so yeah I
one now yeah I have to wait I have to
get get this out so what about see for
now he will take it I guess group here
Bishop c4 I can take and play Knight b6
again again for c4 maybe that is
somewhat playable okay that looks like
an annoying move my knight has no good
squares right f.2d 8 f seven looks
immensely week maybe this yeah here i
was thinking i can maybe give away the
exchange yeah let's do it
drank for the sea 395 and so on okay I
Scott rook rook d5 you know takes their
prolly also good so Knight b6 on 95 96
probably night c 5 days route g5 but
here there's Luke the eighth Queen f6
that's not good that's not good at all
yeah let's do that loop the eight no is
going for that immediately I thought b3
might be still somewhat interesting b3
is threatening yeah I know maybe ok
let's play it cake and now and I do I
have some kind of some kind of idea
night a for loop th
nitey six actually maybe 96 yeah that
covers d8 and the ideas to play whoopsie
to yes but that's just that's not really
threatening that much man maybe nine age
six oopsie tonight 89 morning
fortunately and I'm ate it right f-for
maybe
I'm i checkmated after Bishop a three I
had just not it's just not quick enough
I guess ok I have to play him check my
queen h8 made us the problem yeah no no
check me yeah did I have some counter
play I really didn't I really don't
think it was so bad yeah it says some
counterplay OS is just not on ok there
was there was nothing ok here 96 is
actually not so clear and this is also
not too clear night be 3s giving me a
draw why because 92 is there I really
had the hunch there should be something
so night be three was the move hmm where
an ID to west idea amazing that this
should be a draw check but as possible
and many Perpetual's and this it seems
that I'm holding this computer is giving
equal amazing and this seems to be not
sufficient this is the best here here I
had the feeling maybe there is something
but well computers on +1 it's not like
I'm eight it immediately this thing
now I have no sales come and play it's
really a shame yeah well this this would
be nice but he's just meeting me check
check this is going to be made at the
end hmm yeah the opening result is
really rubbish yeah okay that was just a
1-1 off I really think this is just
complete rubbish this position what
right gets this big Center and like it's
just sitting there doesn't even have the
bishop pair so I don't know people some
people play that opening but it's just
it's just crazy here why this zoom it's
just much better with basically anything
long Castle short castles it's just bad
okay well thanks for watching